hey dr. Berg here I'm sitting in my
massage table here about ready to do a
little instruct on this subject called
pH I want to explain exactly what it is
all the myths there's so much
misinformation on the alkaline acid
levels like everyone is too acid and all
diseases come from being too acid and
you need to alkalize or die let's get
into the truth of what pH is in the
simplicity of how to understand it okay
so let's make pH really really simple
okay when you when you took chemistry
you might have used all these words like
the potentiation of hydrogen and all
these things I don't want to complicate
it I want to make it really simple so pH
is the measurement of acid and alkaline
that's all you need to know about what
it is now it goes from a scale from 1 to
14 with a neutral being 7 okay now that
would be like distilled water so what
happens when the pH goes down it's more
acid lower number is acid from the
seventh when it goes higher than 7 it
becomes more alkaline and the thing to
know is that when you go from a 7 to an
eight
it's by a power of a hundred so it's
it's very very it's not just going up at
one number it's like magnified by a
hundred for example the reference point
that we use for pH is in the blood
in other words the blood the body will
do whatever akin to keep the blood at a
certain constant level and the pH of the
blood has a very narrow range between
seven slightly alkaline seven point four
seven point three four to seven point
four five I mean it's like it has to be
within that range if it drops by one
degree like in the six you will have a
coma you'll be in a diabetic coma or
something like that so you will not be
able to live so we really want to when
people ask what is the pH well what
fluid are you talking about you talking
about the blood you talk about the bow
because every different body fluid has a
different pH
I mean your stomach should be between
like 1 and 3 like that's almost like
battery acid you can digest like
something very very metallic at that
level and then you have the adream the
inside of the adrenal gland which is a
stress clan that should be pretty acid
because those are the all the different
adrenaline hormones and things like that
so apparently it needs that acidity then
we've got the large bowel which is
should be 15.5 it's a very very acid
because remember it's coming down from
the neutral down to six down to five so
each one it goes down is by a power of a
hundred so it's magnified urine should
be acid sweat should be slightly acid
and then we got we have all the
different things that should be alkaline
the fluid in and outside the cell should
be slightly alkaline the tears should be
alkaline the fluid around your brain
should be about 7.5 that's alkaline and
then of course you have the blood and
then the pancreatic fluids all that
fluid coming down from the pancreas and
the bile which is a gall bladder that
needs to be very alkaline to neutralize
the stomach acid which is so acid so we
have this interesting differentiation
between one part of the body and another
and different PHS to create motion and
to create movement and to counter each
other as well because if that food stays
acid into the small intestine you can
burn a hole through and that's called an
ulcer
and so there's you you really need to
identify what tissue you talking about
when you're talking about pH so so
that's kind of like a an overview of
what pH is in the different fluids and
the next part let's talk about what
happens when you're to acid or to
alkaline okay so we have two categories
here we have two acid to alkaline okay
so if the body becomes one way and I'm
talking about blood I'm using blood as a
reference because what happens is that
every other body part will work around
the blood for example your body will
alter a certain pH in your brain just to
keep your blood normal
we'll pull from this fluid to keep your
blood normal okay because blood is the
constant it's the equilibrium reference
point that we call homeostasis which is
the body's ability to adapt to its
environment but keep a constant internal
environment okay to acid you're going to
be coughing coughing too much that dry
cough and that's why an interesting
remedy for that would be calcium it
tends to lower the coffee but you have
to realize something but if your body is
too alkaline you don't you won't be able
to absorb calcium because calcium is
absorbed in an acid medium but it's
interesting calcium is good for coughing
it'll stop it but just make sure you
don't take calcium carbonate that's
limestone you'd be better off chewing on
the cement outside because it's rocks
coma we talked about that in the last
section diabetic coma where the blood
sugars go up and down you become very
very acid and the pH drops in you can go
into a coma that's a very low blood
sugar situation it could be also high as
well so irregular heartbeats it's a body
that's too acid so the thing that I want
you to get out of is treating the
symptom that's why I don't recommend if
you're too acid to take an alkalizer or
take something for it especially long
term maybe short term but not long term
because there's things called alkaline
water right now where I've see people
taking that way too long and the body's
swing over to the opposite side where
they take different remedies to treat
the symptom symptoms are not errors
they're not mistakes they're the body's
reacting to some something and something
wrong it's adapting to something and we
have to understand what's going on I'll
get into the causes of this in the next
section but I just want to explain the
symptoms here but because because you
imagine you could treat each one of
these with a different drug so increase
heart rate weakness in the muscles nause
nausea
we got sleeping but wired so you're
tired but you're wired you can't sleep
you can't wind down well calcium is a
good remedy for that too but we want to
find out why you're too acid
sighing frequently so it's like
especially at night so you can't seem to
get air so son so what happens is that
an acid body will tend a heart to work
harder and I have a lot of people that
will just take calcium they can breathe
better they can actually feel better
just to balance the pH out but sighing
frequently is an acidic body anxious
anxiety it's all part of that same thing
and you will not be able to hold your
breath so if you really want to know if
you to ask to try to hold your breath
you will not be able to hold it past 20
seconds okay because you don't have it's
kind of like gum you don't have any
oxygen because you're running on your
body's so siddik it doesn't have any air
so it's going to run out of oxygen real
fast
okay so we got alkaline now let's let's
look at this decrease potassium in other
words when your body's too alkaline you
don't absorb minerals especially
potassium or calcium now what happens
without potassium is you're going to
crave sweets
you're not going to store sugar so
you're going to have hypoglycemia low
blood sugar issues you you'll get cramps
in your calves you'll have problems with
heart arrhythmias too and but since
potassium is a physiological relaxer
you'll have a hard time relaxing and
winding down and then the pulse rate
also can go up from that just like right
here so you could have both symptoms
right here twitching on the left eyelid
that's an alkaline state as well because
the calcium is now longer in the bone
it's coming out of solution in
depositing on top of the bone on top of
the tissues not in the muscle or the
bone as bursitis tendinitis arthritis
bone spurs kidney stones even gall
stones tartar on the teeth cataracts
that's calcium on the eye or twitching
on the left eyelid so that would be one
of the symptoms hyperventilation
breathing a lot very excessively
arthritis allergies are an alkaline
state and one thing about arthritis I
forgot to mention is that when you take
an orange orange juice and you
drink it that's citrus which is an acid
is very different it will turn into an
alkaline state in your body and
aggravate and already alkaline body so
one symptom for us to know that you're
too alkaline is to eat a bunch of
oranges or orange juice and see if you
have pain in an hour after that if you
do you're too alkaline
okay so we have allergies and and even
the immune system your immune system is
stimulated with acids and that's why you
may think that when you take vitamin C
you can get rid of a cold or get rid of
mucus and things like that it's not the
vitamin C it's the ascorbic acid that
will do it the problem is most people
take the wrong kind they take a
synthetic and they don't take the
natural stuff and then dip throwing
something else off you be much better
off doing the apple cider vinegar works
even better because there's no side
effects so allergies bone spurs yeah
calcium starts building up because your
pH is off low thyroid and then we talked
about the calcium deposits to that start
building up in different body tissues so
so those are the different
characteristics of the different things
that could happen if you're one way
versus the other so next part let's just
talk about what causes these things so
check this out - acid what happens what
what creats that state is ketosis
ketosis is a form of fat breakdown in
the body and it could also be protein
breakdown - by being on it's two sources
one is um very low carbohydrate in the
diet and high protein like in the Atkins
diet or it could come from a diabetes
situation so if a client comes in my
office and their urine is has ketones in
it and they ate sugar that day I know
it's not a healthy ketosis so kita this
is ketosis is okay it could be healthy
state but it could put you into an
acidic state in which you need to
balance it out with more alkalizing
agents that's why we need to add more
vegetables that's why I always recommend
enough vegetables to be able to balance
everything out - not just for because
they're alkaline but because they have
all the nutrients in the minerals
to that you need to help fortify the
different organs that control pH in
other words your pH is controlled by the
kidney and your adrenal glands so but it
but the thing is we don't want to just
treat those glands we want to understand
some of these other mechanisms because
many times it could be you're on
medications or something like that that
could be creating the pH so I want to
get you in it how do you get the full
scope of what's going on so we got
hypoglycemia
okay that's low blood sugars so if you
skip the meal and you get irritable you
need food then you could have that's a
pre-diabetic situation because you have
a history of eating on sugar and then
that can also make you too acid and of
course diabetes can do that too diabetes
comes from eating too much sugar and you
destroy that regulatory mechanism so
that can put you in a NASA state so it
doesn't necessarily have to be the
adrenal the kidney it could be pancreas
junk foods will do it but of course you
know if you don't process refined carbs
like all the refined grains those are
very acidifying sugar of course that's a
given you realize that the average
person consumes about 149 pounds of
sugar a year so every 13 years they
consume 2,000 pounds of sugar that's a
ton of sugar every 13 years that's
enough to create some interesting
effects what you think I mean what type
of effects will create if you if you do
that to the pancreas long enough I mean
sooner or later it's going to be a
problem but I think in medicine what
they do is they'll wait until you get
the disease but they don't put enough
attention on preventing it okay so we
got to acid now we got to alkalyn stress
because the adrenals are kind of
overworked that will put you in an
alkaline state so people say that stress
causes an acid state no it's actually an
alkaline state why because the when the
adrenals are jacked up a lot you start
losing certain things in the urine you
start losing your healthy acids and then
your blood pH go starts going up
alkaline
and that's what happens with that so
stress dumps acid but it also dumps all
the key things - like potassium and
calcium and even salts that's why at
night when you get home if you're
stressed out you mean you might need a
little salt for some reason to kind of
balance some of the PHS okay so we got
vomiting will will cause you be too
alkaline because you're losing all your
your acids and even in your gut you have
bacteria called lactobacillus which
makes lactic acid you have acid forming
bacteria that really need to be there
and when you take antibiotics it
destroys those things so we really need
to not go too far one way or the other
low stomach acids every decade that you
age past 40 you start losing your
stomach acids and you're going to become
too alkaline so dehydration this could
be coming this could come from too much
water why because it's flushing out all
the electrolytes in making dehydration
it's not just not enough water okay
diuretics will wipe out all the
different key minerals that keep your pH
in balance anti acids that was me I used
to take tons and tons of Rolaids and
things from my heartburn but that will
just mess you up till you become more
alkaline so I want to show you if you
can give me those three bottles right
there there are three things I'm going
to show you if you have some of these
these are kind of just quick remedies
that you can take but my point is that I
really recommend that you just eat
healthy and you don't have to worry
about treating too alkaline
or treating these symptoms if you put
back in the diet everything will fall
back into place but here's a couple
things in them that you may want to
consider apple cider vinegar Bragg's is
really a good thing to acidify the body
because it has a lot of potassium and
nutrients and electrolytes as well so
we've got apple cider vinegar take a
little teaspoon and some water
I would recommend
that maybe maybe one time a day for like
a month and then wait a couple months
and then do it again occasionally or
carbonated water this is one of my
favorite if you crave carbonated water
or soda chances are YouTube alkalyn
you're trying to get your body more
acidic by taking carbonic acid that's
what this is so this will help you it
feels like you're hydrated when you
drink and then of course this is one of
my favorite this is some really high
level Italian volcano lemon juice to get
this at the health of store moms but
this stuff right here is very acidic but
it has all these great properties of
fortifying electrolytes so you can do
that too to help you with your pH okay
and then I just have one last point I
want to mention too in the next section
okay so real quick I just want to
explain something because a lot of
people get heartburn and there's several
disease states that are very
counterintuitive for example heartburn
if you take Rolaids and anti acids
what you might not realize that that
this pH of this stomach needs to be one
two three that's like extremely acid now
that pH goes higher and becomes more
alkaline which is always the case
now the pancreas and the gall bladder
which have fluids that are very alkaline
okay they're supposed to come in there
and neutralize this acid but they're
controlled by the stomach so if this
stomach is not asset enough these won't
release in the right amount so that acid
come down and mess things up down here
now so you get indigestion you get
constipation you get lack of digestion
you get bloating and all these other
things right if you measure the acid
reflux that comes up from the Safa cos
you're going to realize that that acid
is very weak it's not very strong if it
was really strong it would burn a hole
to your esophagus but it never does it's
like a sour thing so the stub the acid
reflux that comes
is really coming from down here it's a
waste acid from the bow called lactic
acid and it comes all went through here
to try to compensate for the low stomach
acids so what what do people do they
take an antioxidant and they make it
more alkaline which makes it worse than
next time they eat and they never get
better
there really is no profit in to curing
these conditions it's all about managed
care put you on a pill so you can manage
it the rest of your life so just
understand that the best thing to do for
acid reflux is to take an acid you can
take Petain how to chloride and get it
from healthy store or you can do apple
cider vinegar you'll feel better
but when you take antacids like I did
for years it messed everything up
because in order for this valve to close
this stomach pH has to be one two three
it's like really really acid so then
this valve isn't closed and then we can
label this is another disease disease
called GERD gastroesophageal reflux
disorder all that means is your valves
not closing because you're not acid
enough and they in the negative you
medication which actually makes it gives
you some relief but it never cures it so
in other words acid reflux is really not
enough acid okay and then that can lead
to an ulcer so there's so many different
labels all the way through here you can
call diverticulitis and Crohn's and
pancreatitis and gall bladder syndrome
and irritable bowel
all these things are really just a ph
problem so again instead of treating it
understand it and apply some of these
principles and just get your eating
cleaned up and then everything will fall
back into balance hope you enjoy the
seminar I'll see you the next one